we have to really really cool guest
hosting opportunities available through
the current indy gogo fundraiser at
david pakman.com slash donut of course
to exponentially increase the influence
of non-corporate progressive media
including the david packard show one
perk allows you to guest host the bonus
show with the david pakman show team now
you will join us via skype the way
producer louis used to do when the david
pakman show studios in new york city and
you will allow out you will work with us
to choose the stories that will be part
of the bonus show so we'll work this out
with you we'll figure out a date that
works and you will work together with us
to pick three stories for the bonus show
and we will include you you will be
guest hosting the bonus show of the
david pakman show for our audience but
that's not the only option to guest host
you can also go the next level up and
for a slightly bigger contribution to
the indy gogo fundraiser at david
pakman.com slash donate you will
actually guest host a segment of the
broadcast david pakman show which will
go out to our two hundred radio and
television affiliates at 11pm Eastern 8
p.m. pacific monday through friday on
free speech TV on directv and dish
network as well as youtube clips and in
all of the platforms radio stations
etcetera where the david pakman show
exists uh and that would be absolutely
huge and i know i know Pat would be very
much interested to bringing in another
voice more voices are always good I
would be interested in seeing what
stories they pick out so yeah I want to
see this happen and in full disclosure
you do not get unilateral choice as to
what stories we do when you guest host
we are still going to have some say
after all if we left it up to the
audience it might be pizzagate 24-7
every single episode and we know how
disastrous that could've been for the
show uh so check those perks out and any
others whether you can donate one ten or
a hundred dollars or more you can do it
david pakman.com slash donate